bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre dans fil
Eco l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence aussi avec les titres de cette
édition
emploie la ville de Coignières organise
une fois de plus sa grande journée de
recrutement nous avons suivi un
yvelinois en recherche d'emploi qui
participait à ce salon l'association
Susan Michaud aide les personnes en
recherche d'emploi à créer leurs projets
cette année cette maison de créateurs
d'entreprise fait ses 10 ans l'occasion
de célébrer l'événement avec tous ceux
qui ont pris part à cette aventure
des entreprises estampillées made in
France il y en a plusieurs dans les
Yvelines à l'occasion du salon Made in
France nous en avons rencontré plusieurs
certaines comme blue Lina connaissent un
vrai succès enfin dans notre entretien
de la semaine nous parlerons de l'emploi
des personnes en situation d'handicap
nous en parlerons avec Christian rose
bonsoir vous êtes le président de Cap
Emploi 78 un organisme chargé de
placement spécialisé si nous aborderons
avec vous à cette question à l'occasion
de la Semaine de l'emploi pour les
personnes en situation d'handicap mais
avant cela nous allons en passer en
revue l'actualité de la semaine
comme je vous le disais en titre chaque
homme chaque année depuis 12 ans la
ville de Coignières organise sa journée
de recrutement nous avons suivi le
parcours date des Rahmane pardon à 31
ans cette ivinois accumulé de nombreux
métiers au cours de sa vie
professionnelle mais n'a jamais réussi à
trouver de travail stable regardez ce
reportage signé Anthony Rech
armée de sa pile de CV Abderrahman vient
tenter sa chance parmi les centaines de
candidats dans les allées de ce forum de
recrutement à 31 ans se perdent trois
enfants à un peu fait tous les métiers
de chauffeur-livreur en passant par
maçon ou aide à la personne ce ne sont
pas les compétences qui manquent sur son
CV c'est vrai que c'est compliqué oui je
vous le mens pas c'est très compliqué de
trouver du travail malgré j'ai de
l'expérience après avoir discuté avec
deux recruteurs il s'arrête au stand de
cette entreprise spécialisée dans la
toiture et l'isolation de maison vous
faites un peu de toiture façade
isolation menuiserie bon en fait moi
j'ai fait un petit peu de maçonnerie
j'ai fait du bâtiment 5 minutes
d'entretien il ressort avec un peu
d'espoir
fonctionner et justement ça m'intéresse
et tout se passe bien d'après la
personne là qui recrute ils m'ont dit
que comme quoi normalement il y a de
l'opportunité dans ce
dans ce métier là et qui recherchent
aussi lors de ses 12e journée de
recrutement à Coignières 35 entreprises
étaient présentes la plupart proposent
des postes en CDI sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou sa région
on est ouvert à tout type de profils
comme on disait sur ça qu'on est présent
sur sur le salon donc que ça soit junior
seniors après c'est la motivation qui
compte sur les emplois de commerce ou
notamment et le savoir-être face aux
clients donc à partir du moment où les
gens ont la capacité à faire les choses
et on le projet à faire les choses on
est on est ouvert à tous types de profil
dans les Yvelines 7,2% des personnes
actives étaient au chômage au mois
d'octobre
l'association Suzanne Michot fête ses 10
ans implanté dans les Yvelines elle elle
les personnes en recherche d'emploi et
les porteurs de projets à concrétiser
leur idée d'entreprise mercredi soir cet
anniversaire était célébrée à la mairie
de Versailles la ville qui a vu naître
l'association et là accompagné à ses
débuts de nombreux créateurs
d'entreprises aidés par l'association
étaient présents regardez ce reportage
réalisé avec William elle
Florence Ferret est une créatrice
accomplie ex consultante pour des
cabinets de conseils elle décide en 2010
de fonder son entreprise de produits
cosmétiques biologiques sa rencontre il
y a un an avec l'association Suzanne
Michaud lui a permis de commencer
concrètement cette aventure je pense que
je manquais vraiment de soutien presque
sur le plan psychologique un petit peu
enfin de gens qui m'accompagnent et qui
qui a envie un peu et Suzanne Michaud
l'a vraiment apporté et ils m'ont
accompagné vraiment j'ai fini par
obtenir un prêt d'honneur qui était de
50000 euros donc c'est pas négligeable
c'est un des plus élevés qu'on puisse
obtenir en France et ils m'ont
accompagné voilà ça a duré plusieurs
mois il y a eu des échecs puis on a
réussi mais l'impression d'être ensemble
plus d'un millier de personnes ont été
accompagnées en 10 ans par l'association
25% ont créé leur entreprise et 5% ont
trouvé un emploi salarié cela grâce au
tutorias la force de cette association
tous les candidats que nous accompagnons
nous sommes donc avec deux visibilité de
regard sur la création de l'entreprise
et la préparation de cette création
d'entreprise on travaille vraiment sur
le business plan 58 heures encadre béni
volant les candidats en disant le nombre
de projets et de personnes accompagnées
ne cessent d'augmenter depuis 2004 le
nombre de créations d'entreprises à
quadruplés
qui ont été créées et de nombreux
retours à l'emploi de salariés et aussi
des gens qui tout simplement ont
retrouvé confiance en eux-mêmes pour
aller rechercher activement un emploi et
ça c'était un point fort de
l'association un anniversaire célébré
avec les honneurs pour l'occasion
l'association a lancé son club de
créateurs d'entreprise une façon de
prolonger son action et de faire aux
entrepreneurs un cadeau de plus
à noter que depuis cette année une
antenne a ouverte à de l'association
ouvert à Montigny-le-Bretonneux vous
pouvez y aller sur rendez-vous retrouver
plus d'informations sur le site internet
de l'association Suzanne Michaud le
numérique et l'innovation était au
programme de la 15e semaine école
entreprise dans les Yvelines au
programme réunion d'information visite
d'entreprises et présentation de
différents métiers par des
professionnels ces manifestations ont
lieu un peu partout dans les Yvelines
l'objectif de cette initiative faire
découvrir au collégiens et au lycéen le
monde de l'entreprise afin de les aider
dans leur orientation future un
reportage de la rédaction
travailler dans une entreprise de jeux
vidéo le rêve de nombreux jeunes avec
cette conférence animée par un
professionnel et organisé par la Cité
des Métiers à Trappes c'est collégiens
découvrent les réalités du monde de
l'animation des métiers dont on parle
peu en classe nous enseigne pas vraiment
notre métier ou ce qu'on veut faire on
nous enseigne plutôt quelque chose de
précis ils sont encore un peu loin de la
réalité et
je suis sur un point très bête sur le
niveau d'études qu'il faut avoir par
exemple je sais dessiner je peux faire
du jeu vidéo on a souvent l'impression
que aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui est doué
ce qu'on a fait le fameux doué il a pas
besoin de faire des études et c'est faux
dans les jeux vidéo comme ailleurs il
faut faire des études
de savoir pourquoi j'allais à l'école au
lycée Villaroy le monde de l'entreprise
et de la formation se déplace auprès des
élèves l'institut de formation par
alternance de l'or Auxois présente ses
bts domotique numérique ou électrique au
lycéen les filières en alternance et
apprentissage débouche aussi sur ces
métiers d'avenir même si elle s'est
encore trop peu de jeunes ça a l'air
intéressant à faire ça doit être une
bonne expérience j'imagine mais j'ai pas
trop envie de faire ça je pensais faire
une prépa Mathieu Maths Spé et une école
d'ingénieur ça m'a intéressé mais aussi
j'avais déjà je sais ce que je vais
faire plus tard mais c'est bien de
savoir d'autres filières possibles qu'on
peut faire alpha de l'eurozoi plus de
80% des jeunes en alternance où on
apprentissage sorte diplômé et près de
90% trouve un emploi à la fin de leur
formation valoriser les cursus à
caractère professionnel et déconstruire
certains clichés c'est aussi ça le but
de la semaine école entreprise on est
encore avec des mentalités qui pensent
que l'apprentissage n'est pas une
formule intéressante et où on envoie en
fait les personnes qui n'ont pas des
niveaux
intéressants c'est faux puisqu'on a
quand même des partenariats avec les
universités partenariat avec de grandes
écoles on a des écoles d'ingénieurs donc
on en voit pas quand même des jeunes qui
n'ont pas de niveau sur ces formations
l'alternance et l'apprentissage des
moyens de rapprocher un peu plus les
élèves du monde professionnel l'année
dernière plus de 800 jeunes et
enseignants s'étaient inscrits ou
rencontre école entreprises ils sont
1900 cette année
parlons de bâtiments à présent la cape
de la Confédération de l'artisanat et
des petites entreprises du bâtiment à
inaugurer sa première antenne dans les
Yvelines a Jouy-en-Josas un nouveau lieu
pour ce syndicat professionnel patronal
représentant principal des entreprises
du bâtiment comme nous l'expliquent
Dominique métayer le président de la
CAPEB au micro de William elle
c'est un message fort le fait d'ouvrir
cette antenne sur le département des
Yvelines le 78 puisque nous avions une
implantation
physique sur l'ensemble des quatre des
trois autres départements il ne manquait
plus qu'ici qu'une implantation physique
pour accueillir apporter le service de
proximité à l'ensemble des artisans du
bâtiment des Yvelines c'est inauguration
était aussi l'occasion d'attirer
l'attention sur la situation
particulièrement particulièrement
difficile des métiers du bâtiment
dans le bâtiment que ça soit sur les
Yvelines ou ailleurs
nos trésorerie sont
exemples pour la plupart des entreprises
l'activité n'est pas au rendez-vous et
les entreprises sont vraiment dans une
détresse importante et cette détresse
qui dure depuis maintenant 2008 commence
à se ressentir dans les fermetures
d'entreprises et liquidation
d'entreprises et principalement celle du
bâtiment
il est maintenant temps de passer à
notre entretien de la semaine
cette semaine nous allons parler
d'emploi pour les personnes en situation
d'handicap nous sommes je le rappelle
avec Christian rose président de Cap
Emploi 78 donc Cap emploi c'est un
réseau national qui regroupe 103 103 103
antennes d'organismes de placement
spécialisés au service des personnes
handicapées des employeurs pour
l'adéquation d'emplois compétences et
Handicap alors tout d'abord Christian
rose est-ce que vous pouvez me rappeler
ce que vous faites au sein de Cap Emploi
est effectivement organisme de placement
spécialisé qui est adossé une
association insertion handicapée yuline
qui a vu le jour à l'époque par la NPE
et la dtvp et nous accompagnons les
personnes en situation de handicap vers
l'emploi et nous aidons également sur la
partie maintien 5m 78 les entreprises à
maintenir les personnes en situation de
handicap au sein de leur entreprise
voilà
quelle est la situation des demandeurs
d'emploi ancien sur l'handicap dans les
Yvelines dans notre département
le chômage des personnes en situation de
handicap à considérablement cru ces
dernières années malheureusement pour
elle le contexte économique convient de
l'entendre sur vos reportages et tels
que les difficultés d'accès à l'emploi
pour ces personnes-là en particulier
sont croissantes 5000 demandeurs
d'emploi aujourd'hui reconnu travailler
handicapés un taux de chômage
effectivement de 7 à 8% inférieur certes
à celle de la moyenne nationale mais
quand même préoccupante pour pour les
Yvelines que vous que vous disent les
emplois donc qui sont en situation
requête dans les Yvelines quelles sont
un petit peu leur ressentiment les
problèmes vraiment qui qu'il les
touchent le plus dans leur recherche
d'emploi la difficulté c'est d'abord
effectivement de pouvoir gagner la
confiance des employeurs les employeurs
vous le savez ont un certain nombre de
freins à l'embauche de réticence en
particulier sur le handicap lié à un
absentéisme à une possible maladie à une
difficulté peut-être à accomplir un
certain nombre de tâches des besoins
d'assistance ou d'adaptation qui font
que ces personnes la plupart du temps
ont plus de mal à expliquer
la raison pour laquelle effectivement
tous ces freins sont à lever et pour que
l'entreprise puisse enfin les recruter
est-ce qu'on pourrait dire que le
premier problème est avant tout la
barrière mentale peut-être des
employeurs
oui ça joue effectivement encore
aujourd'hui la société a tout de même
ouvert plus largement sur la diversité
l'égalité des chances hommes femmes sur
le monde du handicap aujourd'hui et sur
la responsabilité sociétale et sociale
des entreprises on a effectivement une
évolution de la mentalité si je puis
dire du recruteur mais
l'immatieté de du besoin de d'une
population formée compétente fait que
aujourd'hui on constate malheureusement
qu'encore un certain nombre un grand
nombre un trop grand nombre de personnes
restent sur le pas de la porte quand on
parle d'handicap on pense souvent à des
handicaps lourds à des choses vraiment
très contraignantes est-ce que c'est
c'est un cliché qui est dans les
entreprises oui oui c'est un cliché
puisque en fait on a très peu de
personnes en situation de mobilité
réduite ou en situation de de déficience
sociorielle qu'elle soit aveugle
malentendantes ou en fauteuil manuel ou
électrique c'est vraiment un cliché
c'est l'identification même de la
personne handicapée aurait que plus de
80% des personnes pour elle handicap est
invisible suite à des difficultés
maladies invalidantes des difficultés de
santé mal de dos station debout pénible
et autres et donc c'est effectivement un
cliché qu'il faut lever puisque la
personne handicapée est une personne
comme vous et moi avec des soucis de
santé et
qui contraignent certes victime à une
adaptation de poste ou à une prise en
compte particulière de l'entreprise ce
qui est un des freins justement à son
embauche est-ce que c'est plus difficile
pour les personnes on va dire qui
naissent avec son diap plat ou pour des
personnes qui ont un handicap au cours
de leur vie comment vous les orientez ce
qu'il y a un travail différent selon il
y a un travail différent sur la
reconnaissance et le déni du handicap il
y a une franchise enfin une étape à
franchir pour pour que lever en fait
cette difficulté et certains même
accèdent à l'emploi sont sans avoir à
parler de leur propre handicap et
craignant que l'employeur refuse leur
candidature
pardonnez-moi donc effectivement tout ce
travail d'accompagnement des conseillers
emploi pour pour lever ces freins et
puis permettre à la personne de d'être à
l'aise et de pouvoir parler de son
handicap de façon à rassurer en quelque
sorte le recruteur qui qui se trouve en
face de la personne
est-ce qu'on va dire que les le facteur
un peu du chômage du chômage pardon
est-ce que c'est plutôt du côté des
entreprises ou peut-être plutôt des
personnes qui n'osent peut-être pas
parfois aller vers les entreprises aller
demander je sais pas un entretien parce
que ils se sentent peut-être pas très
légitime qu'ils ont peur justement du
regard du monde professionnel non je
pense que aujourd'hui la crainte est
levée ont l'organisation de cette
semaine 18e semaine nationale du
handicap permet justement la rencontre
des personnes en situation de handicap
sans sans difficulté avec l'entreprise
cette mise en relation qu'on essaye de
faire tout au long de l'année bien
évidemment prend une part plus active à
cette occasion notamment à l'occasion de
forums ou autre je dirais la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est elle est véritablement
liée à la crise plus économique qu'une
qu'une mauvaise volonté des entreprises
à vouloir recruter ces personnes
rentre donc le secteur tertiaire est
effectivement un des secteurs sur lequel
on reconverti un certain nombre de
personnes on parle notamment du problème
de l'emploi parce que les personnes en
situation handicap n'auraient pas assez
de qualification est-ce qu'il y a un
problème qu'il y a à la formation
peut-être à l'université aux études un
problème donc qui en amont alors en
amont probablement on a encore
malheureusement un certain nombre de
personnes en situation de handicap qui
ont trop faible niveau de qualification
par rapport à aux besoins aujourd'hui
surtout dans les grands groupes et sur
le bassin de l'emploi de 50 ans en
Yvelines en particulier
pour autant l'éducation nationale les
universités font des efforts
considérables
par les universités alors ils ont toutes
maintenant à charger de mission donc
handicap avec lesquels on entretient des
relations également et c'est chargé de
mission entretiennent des bonnes en
relation avec donc les pour
effectivement aider au placement des
étudiants en situation de handicap donc
je dirais que les choses ont quand même
beaucoup progressé évoluer que y compris
au niveau collège et donc lycée nous
avons la plupart du temps des
auxiliaires de vie scolaire qui aident
aussi à l'intégration des personnes donc
on a un être une nette amélioration de
cette situation et plus grand nombre de
jeunes arrivent aujourd'hui en études
supérieures et donc cette situation de
de faiblesse de compétences en tout cas
de niveau d'études progressivement sera
levé s'il y a des normes à respecter qui
effraient les entreprises pour justement
aller vers l'embauche des personnes
handicapées les conditions souvent sont
celles de la d'adaptation des postes de
travail ou voire même de l'accessibilité
proprement dit des bâtiments aujourd'hui
on sait qu'il y a encore de gros efforts
à faire même si la loi vise à attendre à
amélioration des choses un des freins
effectivement peut-être lié à
l'appréhension qu'on les employeurs
d'avoir à verser des bourses adaptés sur
des sièges ergonomiques sur des postes
de travail et autres il faut qu'ils
sachent ces entreprises que donc
l'Agefiph au financement de ces moyens
de compensation que ce soit en aide
technique ou en aide humaine parfois ou
autre moyen de d'aider les personnes
interprétariats de langue des signes et
autres pour favoriser effectivement
l'accueil de ces personnes en entreprise
je vous propose maintenant à Christian
rose de regarder avec nous la question
de la semaine notre question cette
semaine nous avons demandé à vous y
Vinois si vous pensiez que les
entreprises faisaient suffisamment
d'efforts pour l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap
oui dans dans mon entreprise il y a on
est conscient du problème mais je pense
qu'on pourrait aller beaucoup plus loin
je crois que le fait d'être handicapé ne
serait pas ne serait pas un motif dans
mon entreprise de les de les exclure et
pas assez d'efforts qui sont faits
justement pour pouvoir prendre les
personnes handicapées quand on regarde
rien n'est adapté pour permettre
l'accueil justement de ces personnes là
à part dans d'autres endroits comme les
ministères où il y a vraiment beaucoup
d'handicapés qui sont employés dans
l'industrie
c'est pas vraiment le cas il pense que
parce que les handicapés on est moins
capables c'est faux
alors Christian Roy est-ce que vous avez
une réaction par rapport à ce que vous
venez d'entendre
point de vue bien évidemment quand on se
trouve en entreprise on voit qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire on l'a
dit à l'instant
quand on est demandeur d'emploi n'en
parlons pas bien évidemment on se
confronte à la difficulté d'accéder à
l'emploi et donc on considère que les
entreprises ne jouent pas le jeu
je ne dirais pas ça plus d'un millier
d'entreprises sont adhérentes à notre
structure ou en tout cas collabore
activement au placement des personnes
plus de 1000 contrats donc réalisé en
2013 pour les personnes dans les
Yvelines et en Île-de-France donc il y a
un réel effort ceci dit les personnes
qui sont confrontées à ces situations le
vivent souvent mal et ça se comprend
merci Christian rose d'être venu sur
notre plateau nous poursuivons notre
émission avec le chiffre de la semaine
+ 7,6% c'est l'augmentation du chômage
entre 2013 et 2014 pour les personnes en
situation d'handicap en décembre 2013 on
recensé dans les Yvelines
5157 demandeurs d'emploi en situation
d'handicap cela représente environ 7%
des demandeurs d'emploi sur le
département à noter qu'en France ce
nombre s'élève à 400 000
je vous propose maintenant de passer à
notre dossier de la semaine
le made in France est une tendance à la
mode pour les entreprises françaises
cela consiste à produire ou développer
la majeure partie de leur activité en
France dans les Yvelines plusieurs
entreprises ce sont lancées dans cette
aventure made in France nous en avons
rencontré plusieurs au salon Made in
France et vous allez le voir le succès
n'est pas loin un reportage réalisé avec
William hell et Romain russeini
la petite marinière
une marinière tout un symbole pour cette
marque de vêtements made in France
implanté dans les Yvelines à
Triel-sur-Seine cette jeune entreprise
née en 2013 créée confectionne plus de
90% de ses vêtements et accessoires en
France l'objectif premier c'était quand
même de mettre en avant les savoir-faire
de montrer qu'en France aussi on est
capable de créer une marque sportwear et
d'établir tout un univers et en fait par
la labellisation on obtient une première
réussite c'est montrer qu'en France les
savoir-faire existent et ils sont
reconnus un engagement salué par le
label Origine France pour bénéficier de
l'appellation made in France une
entreprise doit produire 50% de son
activité dans l'Hexagone c'est le cas de
cette start-up versaillaise elle propose
sur Internet un abonnement de coffret
avec des spécialités des terroirs la
France c'est un pays qu'on adore où on
parcourt la France tous les mois et on
découvre à chaque fois les trucs
incroyables la moindre petite ville
regorge d'histoire et ça intéresse
beaucoup les gens d'ailleurs patrimoine
oblige la gastronomie largement
représenté au salon sur les autres
stands les nouvelles technologies
occupent de plus en plus de place elle
est dotée d'un système de
géolocalisation et d'un bracelet
sécurisé pour éviter que la personne
dans un accès de soit de folie ou juste
qui est envie de l'enlever ne puisse pas
l'enlever cette opérateur d'objets
connectés dédié à la santé est un invité
de marque du salon l'entreprise
représente l'innovation made in France
basée à Élancourt elle connaît un vrai
succès version française
sont bien placés à nous on utilise en
fin de compte des objets connectés qui
ont été souvent fabriqués par d'autres
pour pouvoir les intégrer dans un
système d'information un cockpit pour
pouvoir suivre des personnes créer en
2006 blue Lina propose différents
équipements pour le maintien à domicile
s'ils ne sont pas tous entièrement
produits en France l'entreprise propose
en plus un service avec des opérateurs
conseillés en relation permanente avec
les clients il répond aux appels en
direct de Paris ou d'Élancourt la
logistique la conception le service
après-vente se font eux à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est plus
simple pour le SAV c'est aussi parce que
nous avons de petits volumes
ça peut paraître énorme on suit près de
12000 particuliers alors domicile mais
en même temps on n'achète pas un million
de bracelets ou un million d'objets
connectés donc autant les produits et
les concevoir en France dans le secteur
de la santé et de l'accompagnement le
made in France fonctionne bien la cible
des seniors qui sollicitent un
accompagnement si prête particulièrement
470 établissements d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées font déjà appellent au
service de l'entreprise le côté
fait sur place mis au point sur place
garantie sur place forcément ça
introduit de la confiance en deux ans
l'entreprise est passée de 2 à 90
employés son chiffre d'affaires s'est
multiplié par 9 il devrait dépasser les
4 millions d'euros pour l'année 2014
c'est peut-être ça le rêve français
et dans notre agenda cette semaine deux
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer ce mercredi
26 novembre c'est la 14e journée
pédagogique des professions du chiffre
l'événement principalement dédié aux
élèves a lieu toute la journée au
Théâtre du Chesnay au programme réunion
d'information et découverte des métiers
d'expert-comptables et de commissaire
aux comptes pour participer il faut
s'inscrire dans le cadre de la Semaine
école entreprise une société ouvre ses
portes au public c'est l'entreprise
Icare la société fabrique des outils
pour l'industrie mécanique demain à
l'accueil toute la journée des scolaires
et samedi matin elle reçoit les élèves
et leurs familles là aussi il faut
s'inscrire vous pouvez contacter la Cité
des métiers
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro des Philippot je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée